hi it's silver at again and today I'm
just going to do some random little
things that need to be done so I need I
just want to cover a couple of things in
this small video so first of all there
is the exit and obviously up until now
I've left this exit just out there and I
didn't really do anything with it but of
course I need to get that exit out
somewhere I need to connect it to some
parts somewhere so I think I'm just
going to keep it simple and straight to
the point and just gonna add a simple
little path over here that goes over
here and then connects it to the main
path okay so I'm just going to leave
these things and I'll be fine I'll just
repair that later on now important for
me at the moment is that I get a good
while conforming paths at sins there's
some hilly stuff over here so I'm gonna
get one of my favorite conforming paths
that's that being Ralphie's path cover
sets it has it doesn't have too many
pieces it doesn't have the diagonal two
straight pieces that are sometimes
necessary but then again it does have
some nice curve pieces and it does have
really interesting textures like this
one I think I'm actually gonna go for
this pebble texture now of course it is
important to delete all of them crunch
rubbery that you that that's kind of in
the way over here so I want to be
careful with these things because
sometimes you miss click and then you
remove them okay so I think I need a
quarter piece this is sat even have
quarter pieces
oh it's glitching now that's not very
good is there a way to prevent this from
happening
nope there is no way to prevent that
that is very unfortunate hmm that means
you know what I can also just do I can
also just kind of make make it go like
that okay I'll cover that later that's
nice anyway so I'm just going to
continue along the way if this lets see
and a small little curve here you know
that should do many sets actually have a
quarter of curve so if you if you do
have a quarter curve and it in here but
this set doesn't have one so yeah it's
gonna be hard to add one then okay now I
do want to repair this now this is
something that's like
sometimes do I I just find it I just
find it to look more of healing so
basically the way it ends is also I'm
gonna go into the foliage part because I
do want conforming pieces you kind of
have a little curve into the exit path
so I'm gonna see if that's possible in
this case and open the path set again it
doesn't seem like there's an actual
quarter curve in this pot set but then
again I can also just use these like
that so I'm going to remove this okay
that's very nice and of course this one
is already diagonal and it's already a
heading in that direction so all I have
to do is just add one to that and repair
that one and then repair the fences as
well okay now I do want this to be even
so I'm gonna repair this like that okay
and now it's of course it's time for
Brian chest fence set again get that
nice little wood thingy okay that's
beautiful and mm-hmm it doesn't seem
like there's actually a curve conforming
piece and that's how it's very
unfortunate because I do want this to
match up with that hmm like the only
other thing that I can do you know I'll
just make it straight I don't want to
have a different fence there's no way I
can remove all those fences and replace
them and everything so I'm just going to
do like this that's also possible
doesn't look quite as good but yeah
there's no way no other way of really
fixing this so I'm just gonna doing like
that okay
now of course there's one thing to keep
in mind which is the fact that I still
need to add poles having any poles like
this doesn't make too much sense but
then again I might still add something
to it just need to kind of experiment
with that because basically I am I am
just a person I just like adding little
items and things like that so I think
I'm actually going to add one of those
things in this thing so for example I
think it's station Jim's gone inning two
that has though has those nice things
yeah yeah these these these I don't know
why but I just like using these when you
have you can use them for
for entrances as well it's just a nice
little nice little extra detail I just
like it okay now of course I still need
to add fences to everything and this
thing still needs to be supported and
that's something that's somewhat hard to
do with modern buildings scenes with
many styles you can just add wooden
posts and beams but in this case that's
pretty much impossible to do since yeah
it's in a modern style so I'll have to
come up with some other ways okay now
one other thing I'm going to come back
to that later on but one other thing
that I can't stand at the moment is the
paths I just look at that paths and
they're so bright
you rarely have paths that have Sanders
that is this bright and in any way I
don't really find it looking that
appealing so there are two ways of going
about making this less bright actually
there are multiple ways you can just use
this sand which is easy but there's
another way which I'm going to show I'm
not going to use it because it takes too
much time but if you do have time time
on your hands and this is something that
I've covered in a tutorial before in my
advanced hair painting tutorial you can
use certain schemes to certain patterns
to oops I messed that one up
to make a your own texture basically and
get a nice looking texture that works
really nicely for your parts so you can
do stuff like that but I've also I think
of even at some point used asphalt and
stuff as well though I'm not entirely
sure but this is do something that you
can experiment with as you can see you
can just mix the textures and create
loads of awesome new things but in this
case I'm just gonna be lazy and replace
them all with this slightly darker Sun
texture I would have liked to kind of
mix it with another slightly darker to
San texture that's again slightly darker
than this one but then again that would
take so much time and I I don't think
it's really worth it for this rind in
particular since you know this one seems
to do fine as well
yeah really like the look of this okay
so I'm just going to replace all of
these things and there we go so as you
can see it's a little less bright and
less out there and it looks more like a
real path coffee now okay because one
thing to remember is that this is an
actual path it's not some sandy road or
some little sandy something but it's an
actual path that I will have to turn
into an actual path the sidewalks at
buildings and all of that so having a
really really bright yellow scent
actually on that it's never really
something that you you'd want to have
okay so that looks a little bit better
now to fix this little exit thing I'm
just going to do something that's
similar to the thing that I did in my
alpha coaster I think that's what it is
okay so first of all I'm going to open
Moby's curved walls now you can use
pretty much any curved wall set that
that you like for this another good
choice would be one a brine chess board
as sets that I have used before I'm
pretty sure yeah I've used those they're
in the same set as the fences and all
that stuff so that's really handy but I
just really like the texture and certain
thickness of this sets for certain walls
like these so I'm just going to use this
right here and I think I'm actually
going to make them make them white yeah
that probably looks better okay yeah
that's a little bit better now I'm just
going to add these little things to kind
of add some more shape to the path
because right now that's so flat and I
don't want that before I support
anything before you support path so it
stairs in anyway I always like to make
them a bit more thick since basically a
size like this wouldn't even be able to
support its own weight though I must say
it's a different thing with women the
stairs if you have wooden stairs you can
make them flat perfectly fine actually
that's probably a better idea but in
this case I just like to do this okay so
I'm going to do that on the other side
as well so as you can see you can you
get that little nice little border there
we go and we're almost done with that
then obviously all you still need to do
is just the horizontal pieces but
they're always a lot easier so that's
really nice
okay now let's see this should be
horizontal pieces now okay there we go
little part of the set basically the top
part of the set has all the horizontal
and simple pieces then you get apart
with all the curves and there you get
all the the angle the slope thingies
okay now that it's pretty much time for
a fence
I couldn't already work in the supports
but supports are really annoying so I'm
going to do the defense first let's see
now again there are many ways of dealing
with the fences but as I've already used
the fences and these fences in the
station over here and my way I need to
not forget to do that one as well
I'm just going to use the same fence now
this is also something that I would
recommend you to do if you have a fence
and you have a stair just you use the
same fence it just makes more sense I
guess okay so station gyms fencing once
again and let's see get that slope to H
I think yep do make sure it has the same
color scheme though okay that should be
all rights blue things yeah and white
things in the middle wait actually no
it's a different shade of blue okay
there we go that should be good
okay perfect okay and this always takes
a bit of time but it's not that annoying
and sometimes I end up with with just
some weird stairs that I really don't
like but in most of the cases some
experimentation will get me there at
some points that was an awful lot like
spike now when it comes to support star
in many ways of dealing with this but I
think that in this case I'm just gonna
go with AM support on the sides like I
did with alpha I'm just gonna play it
safe I would never recommend playing it
safe but just for the sake of this
tutorial I'm gonna do that since it's
less time-consuming but I'm definitely
experimentation is a large part of the
time you spend in roller coast like
three just messing around with SATs
messing around with ideas that you have
just in general trying new things it's
it's really great most of the times you
will fail miserably and you'll create a
spectacularly terrible stuff but then
sometimes you just got this amazing
things and it's it's sometimes really
works okay now I still need to make that
thing underneath it over here so
definitely want to do that right away
let's see close that's all so I set this
in my alpine village tutorial but don't
be like me close your SATs all the time
unless you're busy with two SATs um
while basically one after another but in
any case close your SATs if you're not
working on them with them because it
just turns into a mess if you have all
these open sets okay that's pretty cool
and the other side again yeah that looks
pretty good I guess that works it's
definitely something that needs to work
on both sides
sometimes something looks nice on one
side which is because of the
environments the general context of what
everything looks like it doesn't work on
another side but I'm glad that it works
on both sides it goes nicely with that
with the q2 now supporting is gonna be
somewhat annoying but I think I'm just
like I said I'm just gonna play it safe
and do some simple stuff so in this case
I'm going to take shy guys what a world
SATs now this is a trick that I often
use because this thing has these poles
these support things and they're
basically the same as Mobe steel jungle
except they're slightly smaller so I
always like to use them when I do one
supports but I don't want to them to be
quite as thick as you can see if you I
compared them to Moby C which I know you
can really see that though just a bit
smaller hmm making these white though is
probably not the greatest idea no I'm
still gonna go for it white is really if
you if you're making modern buildings
white as the color to use in any case
when you're in doubt use whites white
will make any building look modern
basically and gloss loads of glass and
steel basically cliches cliches are very
true okay but this system also works
with wooden stairs by the way so if you
if you making wooden stairs you can also
use the this poor system and everything
now the handy thing of this set is that
it even includes some fritters and
they're really nice and they really fit
the supports to somes gonna use these
over here that's pretty cool it's a
shame that it sinks into the ground like
this because it does mean that you'll
have to raise it you don't want photos
to kind of sink it to the ground
you really want them to form a nice
concrete block so like that that just
barely makes it
okay good now of course there's no
terraforming over here so it's gonna be
a lot easier then okay so that looks
pretty decent now one last thing I want
to finish the fence around this little
thing now I don't quite know which fence
I do want to use for this but hmm you
know what I guess I can just continue to
use that the CTRs since parts set so I'm
just gonna try that I think it Huck
I think it has curbs in it but I'm not
entirely sure let's see CT or spots it
should be in here
oh wait that's the wrong part of the
sites in now western-themed let's see
CTOs paths - oh that's a shame there's
actually no curve in it hmm that means
I'll make I have to make this straight I
I guess that's the only way I could you
you could go ahead and just find another
fencing set but I feel like I really
want to have this fencing set because it
really goes with the texture and
everything that I'm having right now so
I'll just make that little thing kind of
straight but don't make it entirely
straight that'll just make it look like
roller coaster tycoon and you don't want
it to look more like coach that [ __ ]
surprisingly you don't so I'm gonna add
a small diagonal section over here also
need to take care of that and just kind
of pretend like it's a curve like that
which somewhat works okay though I'm not
sure where they actually worked with the
path covers it might actually not work
hmm you know what just in case that the
path covers don't have a piece for that
I'm gonna connect these so if they don't
have a piece for that I'm just gonna
make them straight I'll give up but I
don't have to go back since I've already
placed two of the possibility so this is
also a tip that I would give I used to
spend so much time experimenting opening
ass at placing something opening another
sack that it turns out that it doesn't
work just if you want to experiment with
different sets just try multiple
possibilities especially
with path covers and fences like that
because it's very easy to do this okay
so that's good now let's see
Ralphie's path covers where are they
over here so I don't think this is going
to quite work out now is it
I'm nope no I'm just gonna have to make
that straight yeah I gave up on it okay
now I might want to add different fence
though so I'm just going to see if there
are any fences that I like she's gonna
kind of scroll around okay so I just
wasted my time on these rustic ropes
over here because I placed them and then
it turned out that they didn't have
conforming pause so I couldn't actually
support them so if you have conforming
stuff going on I'd say don't use rusty
rope fences because they're gonna mess
everything up so in this case I am
probably just gonna go with the mesh
fences because that should actually work
shouldn't be too much of a problem if
the corners don't have pores for this so
I'm just going to do it like that plus
it it still looks pretty cool so I'm
happy okay and then we're done then
that's it for today so looks pretty nice
it's really shaping up right now we got
the queue pretty much finished still
need to add lights and other things but
the Grunch shrubbery and the basic stuff
is done right here so that's pretty cool
so see you all next episode in which I'm
going to do some other small things so
till then